bonsoir gérard vespière merci d'être
avec nous un procès qui semble donc
doublement condamné à ne pas aboutir
puisque d'une part les accusés sont
absents info d'extradition et que la
turquie semble vouloir se réconcilier
avec ryad qu'elle peut être selon vous
dans ce contexte son issue on va écouter
je pense que la porte va doucement se
refermer parce que d'abord il ya aussi
eu un procès en arabie saoudite même
n'est ce pas il ya eu 11 personnes sur
le banc des accusés cinq condamnations à
mort trois condamnations de prison et
trois acquittements dans voyez vous il
ya eu aussi ce volet de la faire donc je
crois que la turquie a besoin de ceux de
renouer des contacts avec l'arabie
saoudite pour des questions économiques
et aussi ces questions économiques sont
destinés à améliorer à l'image
intérieure du président erdogan car il
est en difficulté sur le plan économique
et il a besoin effectivement de
retrouver des flux commerciaux avec
l'arabie saoudite
oui parce qu'il faut préciser que toutes
les exportations ont baissé de 90% dans
le pays et les dirigeants turcs
s'abstiennent du coup désormais
d'évoquer cet assassinat est pointé du
doigt publiquement le trône saoudien
tout à fait vous avez cité ce chiffre
avant que je ne le fasse donc il y a un
besoin parce que l'économie turque est
un retournement après quinze années
glorieuses 2000 à 2015 maintenant il ya
eu six dia tôt cette année des
difficultés avec la situation du coc
vide
avec la sécheresse l'environnement est
tout à fait défavorables et récolte de
blé sont à 30% à la baisse cette année
en prévision donc voilà il y aura moins
de touristes à cause du coc vide
vraiment l'arabie saoudite a besoin
d'une aide extérieure pour que le
président r de gan qui luttent contre le
temps car il y a des présidentielles
en turquie en juin 2023 donc c'est
bientôt très bientôt alors que en arabie
saoudite
eh bien on est dans le temps long le
prince est jeune il est héritier s'il
n'y a pas de d'avatar il a quelques
dizaines d'années devant lui alors que
le président erdogan il ya quelques
dizaines de mois seulement alors cet
assassinat particulièrement brutale 1
prouve selon certains experts l'excès de
confiance de moyenne 25 man et
l'impunité que lui procure le
blanc-seing américain cette impunité est
ce qu'elle est toujours d'actualité avec
la mandature biden il n'y a pas
d'impunité je pense que on est là à la
limite ne sont pas des choses
les etats-unis ont laissé apparaître des
dossiers qui effectivement un implique
le nbs ma belle belle salmane a lui même
habilement dit dès le départ
pratiquement à je suis responsable
ça veut dire je ne suis pas coupable
n'est ce pas on connaît la fameuse
formule en france responsable mais pas
coupable
donc il a sous son autorité des gens qui
auraient effectivement lancé cette
opération mais il faut savoir il faut
savoir que à khashoggi était sur le
point d'être nommé un porte-parole
international des frères musulmans est
donc là on est dans cette bataille
politique entre les familles princières
de l'arabie saoudite et de tout le golfe
et donc dé la stratégie des frères
musulmans d'un pouvoir civil
même avec une connotation bien sûr
fortement religieuse là on sait pourtant
que rabaska chaude y étaient au départ
assez proche du pouvoir et notamment du
du prince héritier
ou bien quelles ont été les raisons de
cette dissidence
je pense qu'il a mené sa propre
évaluation de la situation et donc il a
il a souhaité s'éloigner du pouvoir
royal
le pouvoir royal a averti en disant
qu'il le prenait effectivement des
risques lui a proposé de revenir et de
continuer à travailler en arabie
saoudite
certainement avec des incentive que l'on
dit en mauvais français n'est ce pas des
incitations à à venir à nouveau ses
tables iran en arabie saoudite
il a refusé et donc effectivement la
situation est devenue un un peu hors de
contrôle mais se place politiquement
dans le conflit l'attention en trois les
frères musulmans et les pouvoirs donc
monarchique de l'arabie saoudite et du
golfe gervais sperme et dernière
question
on a le sentiment d'une forme
d'indulgence un tout de même envers
l'arabie saoudite
imaginons que ce soit la russie avec
l'aval d'un vladimir poutine qui serait
responsable mais pas coupable
ça sent règlerait à coups de sanctions
oui j'ai une bonne analyse mais vous
voyez vous quand il y à des
interventions d'état il y a des
ministres français qui se sont retrouvés
dans des étangs il y à des opposants
russes qui ont été aussi d'éliminer donc
voilà il y a les raisons d'état ils font
que quelquefois les choses ne vont pas
plus loin
très bien c'est clair merci gérard
vespière je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste géopolitique merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france